yeah welcome to this video game playing
be 45 against the drum player here
producer dr. rare line and the ruler
pesticide d4 line it's not particularly
a great butt down it's sometimes played
that's tricky to always tricky to to
play cuz into remember those those red
lines something like this is so is the
theoretical way to play but i don't i
don't recall it in detail okay let's um
I didn't expect to be one okay
yeah this is the kind of line where
white gets some early activity and the
question is does he get anything
substantial or is it just really a
temporary thing if it is then Black has
no problems at all because yeah we've
got I got not anymore two bishops so
what now Queen d7 I cannot play all
right this is somewhat somewhat annoying
already I probably am made some some
move all the mistakes yeah if you know
what you're doing this line is really
harmless but it's not so easy to
remember it and to not spend too much
time on it don't know that I can take
now maybe take all of 695 clocks oh yeah
doesn't look too nice
yeah I think maybe taking 95 I can take
me to it it somewhat looks very cry can
play 97 even so taking f 695 is just a
good movie too long this was probably
the idea okay let's then let's provoke
this movie to a son otherwise not really
helpful move least I don't do don't see
the point that resides book d to e tool
and some bad some sub-state yeah I
expect bishop edge form but he's some
thinking the longer
okay yeah this now simplifies the
position quite them quite a lot cannot
take on be too of course but okay I
can't get rid of this and he cannot take
with the poor now need to take with the
Queen so it's probably am around equal
ok he's got he's got us a bit a bit a
bit of a pool it's not much but it is
it's a bit annoying yeah I'd like to
employ Mookie eight but it's not it's
not possible at the moment I have some
weakness on the queenside now if i get
rid of the rooks I don't think his son
he's having much I'm just covering
discovery my stuff now
yeah this should be equal now I mean a
success is some theoretical a bit too
bit weak but i have three really we can
the dark squares yeah i'll put something
on the dark squares
i don't know i'm not quite sure what he
is doing here the words erotic was just
playing on with some some moves take him
should i go here i can take down but to
Queen d2 122 should should be let's not
let's not draw exactly but I can take c2
I mean taking all the f7 would really be
quite strange I can take a greedy to
check out quincy too and then i have
furthered upon which we should probably
just draw with Queen at five and quit c8
with the perpetual
check
okay yeah okay this is valid and this is
covering the the weakness here to see to
weakness
yeah is he playing for for wind I mean
we don't position all our time don't
really think so I maybe is try to do it
everything but it says justified yeah I
wondered about that even even the move
before is this what to make of the the
Queen's right here we should just give
the checks what
really cool kingi fall
yeah this was one idea like hmm kimchi
kimchi for us we need bit down a bit
strange I just need to draw yeah I think
I mean why should why should white be
better him and I'll you are the pawns
but in King's you form is a bit like
like a stuntman thing trying to be extra
time yeah I just thought okay let's
bring this into into action but after
Queenie for it gets immensely strong you
can probably should to do something
something like that and evacuate the
King this in this way the otherwise it
was it was pretty equal yeah thanks for
watching